Họng 1 năm giờ 3 mưu thuộc qua 2 tháng 6 năm năm 2018, anh với sôn tê,
sinh 1 mừng chiến trăm chim mi ba, 1 thơ Mỹ ngọt, sã nước liên,
phyền vũ qua, tình hà tính, ra cánh đồng đồng dê, sã nước liên để thú hạnh lỗi muồ.
Thưa điểm trên, thưa tiếp tại khu vực mua nhỏ kênh sâm sét.
Lúc này, anh tê đang sự dụng để thoại sê em cơm nha đã anh anh tả nhà để thân sỗi tình yên con cái
không mai bị sế bất ngờ đánh chúng từ vòng tại số.
Bản đồ sẽ cập nhật cho thấy, khi này, bông đang có mua dông mạnh và sế đánh đang tập trung ở mi bác,
người dân cần lưu ý, khi thấy bởi hiện con dông kém sâm sét,
cần nhé trong tìm nơi chủ ẩn ảnh tòa, tình đối không ở lại ngoài trời,
nhất là những không dành dọc, vình đồng dụng, sông hồ.